parada mit superman sich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video ich will ganz
ehrlich hat deutschland zwar habe ich
einfach vergessen für heute ein video
vor zu produzieren und ich waren erst
mit studienkollegen hatten wir ein
shooting für den lukas shop da bleibe
ich euch mal was von snap chat 1 da
kommt ein neues t-shirt sechste lukasz
ob deswegen war ich deswegen bei einem
shooting jetzt gleich muss ich in sieben
minuten oder so ok ich muss in vier
minuten eigentlich ein kumpel vom
bahnhof abholen allerdings wirkt sich
das ist einfach mal dafür oder thema
anzusprechen was mir in letzter zeit ein
bisschen prassen negativ aufgefallen ist
es gibt nämlich etwas war dass ich mit
euch reden möchte und es liegt mir echt
am herzen und es ist wirklich das
schwarzwild als deswegen ich will es gar
nicht was mit schwarzweiss filter und
trauriger musik und natur ihren losen
bild runtergerutscht kommen will ich das
gar nicht machen sondern sich einfach
nur gut meine meinung sagen ich denke
alle die meine videos schauen wissen es
sich nicht wirklich ein sehr trauriger
ein wichtiger mensch bist sondern
eigentlich eher fröhlich und so möchte
ich das thema auch behandelt werden weil
gibt video was ich gestern hochgeladen
habe habe ich einen gameplay als
hintergrund benutzt um über ein thema zu
reden das war ja wohl lieber im italo
sind dann wenn ich euch mal was alle ich
weiß ich bin nicht der beste spieler ich
hab' ich habe verloren tatsächlich ich
bin die aufnahme geht eine minute beim
kostenlose video dem ich schon gesehen
das hat nicht so ganz geklappt
ich konnte mich nämlich eigentlich fast
gar nicht auf das thema konzentrieren
oder besser fünf minuten angefangen
darüber zu reden
deswegen hier ein
die talk oder gameplay im hintergrund
und deswegen wird auch hoffentlich nicht
allzu lang jetzt wahrscheinlich schon
tipps und zwar ich mache was ich will
und darum soll es gehen schon jetzt mal
so ein bisschen aus und zwar die
plattform youtube relativ früh bereits
entdeckt durch den kumpel jonas ist
youtube nicht so belassen wie es
geschrieben geht mit browser und ub ein
vater ihn mit 14 oder so
die ersten videos die ich dort gesehen
habe waren von alpro kommt und den aus
salz hat und wenn ich wieder hin content
von denen angeschaut habt brown hat
wirklich einfach gameplay aufgenommen
hat das klopfen von dem von der taste
gehört aber davon zu labern herzi
bekommt ein baby und fakt seit einer
viertelstunde wieder drauf hat also
hochgenau alberto hat beatbox videos
aufgenommen wo es auf das ende der sein
poster als kamera benutzt soll schlechte
quali hatte das und zu guter letzt die
außenseite videos gebracht wie sie getan
haben als werden sie irgendwelche
komischen antwort leute haben sich ultra
summe angestellt und haben das auch
irgendwie ein bisschen geschnitten
deshalb prüfe der konzern von youtube
und dadurch habe ich die plattform
entdeckt und lieben gelernt so und das
hat ein bisschen gezeigt egal was man
von content macht man sollte einfach
sein ding machen worauf man bock hast
und dann gucken sie sich die leute an es
gab auch damals schon so sehen wie
professionelle karriere wo leute
versucht haben so hall bewerben
youtube zu machen und das so richtig
professionell mit kameras und so habe
ich finde da steht nicht für youtube für
youtube steht du hast eine kamera und du
machst das worauf er bock hast also der
slogan motto wird wie heißt das genau
das was unter dem youtube logo
eigentlich war doch steht und gerade bei
meinem konto ist es mir in letzter zeit
sehr stark aufgefallen dass sehr viele
leute meinen sie dürften darüber
bestimmen was sie hochzuladen habe und
wie ich mich zu verhalten habe ist es
mein leben und mein content und ich
bestimme was ich hochladen
sorry falls es ein bisschen böse kam so
ein typ bin ich eigentlich hatte ich
habe zum beispiel vor drei vier tagen
video hochgeladen wie ich meine haare
mache
das video sowie drei vier tage online
und hat schon fast millionen aufrufe und
dass wir auf der einen seite die leute
interessiert ich dafür schauen sich das
allerdings hat negative kommentare wie
du sagen
bis vor die [ __ ] nach oben weil
ich nur meine haare wache alter schwede
was von der gesellschaft sind wir hier
übrigens doch es ist toll aus wasser
besteht meine videos und das ist nämlich
genau die sache das war eine perfekte
überleitung das hier ist genau luca das
ist ein typischer luca mit einem video
gucke ich auf meine lampe man eben
scheiße der landesstelle handel pflanze
rein das ist mein style
wenn ihr das nicht feiern denn verpisst
euch ich hoffe dass ein paar aufgaben
gerade echt unserer größe sind aber mich
fragt einfach ab dass leute sich das
recht nehmen darüber urteilen zu dürfen
was ich mache meine nachbarn division i
was ich hier würde die eigentlich die
pornos locker denke es ist komisch
springende punkt gekommen
springender punkt die nächsten tag
trinken
es ist zum beispiel ein typischer locker
dass ich am ende klatsche dass ich
die sind anders wird auch kritisiert das
schreiben leute die können wieso
klatschen am ende des new yorker sei
nicht so gemeint
jetzt kommen vielleicht die leute mit
der aussage an jan luca durch soft
einiger zeit selber darüber beschweren
dass einige youtube hochladen ich habe
dazu auch immer noch die gleiche meinung
wenn es um content angebot ich sage ganz
offen wie den von katja glaser witz das
ist nämlich ein witz was die hochnehmen
logan hochredet richard soll ich mich
mal vergraben gar nicht erschlossen
verraten
das war es dass die hochlädt kann ich
einfach nicht mit meinem gewissen
vereinbaren also die legten besonders
auf youtube hoch das ist kompletter
schwachsinn das ist nicht das wofür die
plattform steht in einer gewissen form
achtet natürlich das worauf sie bock hat
und das sollte man auch überhaupt nicht
infrage stellen allerdings muss man sich
da fragen ob dann youtube nicht entweder
falsche plattform für sie ist dass er
sehr darauf bezogen dass ich vor einiger
zeit selber videos gesagt habe was das
denn soll dass jeder für special auf
einmal anfängt zu singen obwohl die sich
anhören wie die letzten die restliche
zeit bin ich weg sein aber wenn man da
bock drauf hat so wird das geld machen
und so weit habe ich vor ein paar wochen
einfach noch nicht gedacht ich habe mir
nur gedacht sich euro leute was soll das
dann könnte ich singe auf junge du hast
weil du kannst überhaupt nicht war
einfach auch damit wirklich leute über
mich sagen dass ich einfach nicht
unterhaltsam will dass ich richtig reden
kann dass ich scheiße aussehen das gibt
es immer aber deswegen auf das zu tun
was mir spaß macht
nein tue ich nicht man muss vielleicht
ein paar leuten hinterfragen ob sie ein
paar aktionen ich wegen dem spaß
durchführen sondern wegen dem geld was
dahinter steckt aber das ist ein anderes
thema um auf den punkt dann auch den
titelsong bisschen zurück zu kommen
freunde ich mache was ich will da es auf
youtube bezogen oder einige sagen lukas
studierte materie
hauptberuflich macht deine videos mal
länger als sieben oder zehn minuten
macht wieder 20 minuten joggen macht
dies macht dass mein freund ist mein
leben und ich glaube es ist alles selber
bestimmen und ich weiß im internet kam
ich nicht durch seine video sagen okay
dann alle auf damit alle hören auf ein
paar leute wenn es immer noch machen
aber vielleicht öffne ich dadurch ein
paar die augen erst mal durchatmen das
war es ein bisschen auch die allgemeine
gezogen aber auf meinen kanal und auf
mein konto in letzter zeit bezogen
ich sag sehr aufgezogen stimmt sagt
beispielsweise vor zwei jahren uncut
minecraft video hochgeladen vor einem
jahr habe ich geschnittene minecraft
videos hochgeladen vor einem halben jahr
habe ich mein krampf geschnitten und
andere games geschnitten aufgeladen und
derzeit ladezeit real life geschnitten
und ein bisschen andere gegend weil das
derzeit meine person ist ich habe mehr
lust mich vor der kamera zu stellen um
mit euch zu reden über themen zu reden
euch sachen über mich zu erzählen
instagram kommentare beantworten fragen
videos anzuschauen
sowas gericht und das ist der luca der
gerade so lust auf youtube hat und ich
sage euch wenn ich jetzt wieder lese wo
leute schreiben ja ich hab mich damals
ab und ihren vor drei jahren wurde
unserem ein fachplaner ist ungeschnitten
das war so geil ich de abonniert ich
jetzt die guten zeiten nicht vergessen
dass ich jetzt wieder dieser luca wäre
denn sowas machen würde dann hätte ich
keinen spaß beim youtube wird von
letzter woche durchziehen und dann würde
ich aufhören mit youtube ich will das
hochladen worauf ich bock habe weil
sonst die komplette plattform youtube
keinen spaß wenn ich von leuten in eine
schiene gedrängt werde in der ziemlich
haben möchte ich will zum zugfahren der
nicht an der schiene fährt
und die leute sagen wenn sich dahinter
erinnern dass ich mal hier fahren paar
mal hier mal hier und das ist mein weg
denke die ganze zeit so anstatt eine
schiene wo die leute sagen was ich
machen soll
ich hoffe ihr verstand was ich sagen
möchte es geht einfach darum freunde
egal ob aufwendig jetzt beauty videos
machen würde was ich nicht machen werde
keine sorge ich hasse es dass leute so
sehr darüber urteilen und meinen sie
haben das recht zu sagen was er zu tun
und zu lassen sollte ich meine ich habe
euch meine tipps gibt wie youtube vor
allem denken die bands langer zeit und
da gebe ich auch in jedem interview
letztens mit dem spiegel hat ist als der
wirt zum pc gaming alliance sehen so was
die goldene regel für youtube es gibt
keine goldene regel man kann auch sehr
viele sachen achten wie beispielsweise
dass die qualität des videos gut ist
dass wir gute audioqualität er dass es
nicht und schafft ist das licht fast et
cetera aber was jeder immer beachten
sollte jetzt man selbst zu sein weil
wenn man sich vorstellt und direkt
verkappter wird wenn ich als auch das
video nicht auf die message ein bisschen
mitgenommen und wenn ihr das getan habe
freue mich über die bewertung und
schreibt mir die kommentare was ihr
davon